[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily the
biden administration backs down on its
vaccine and testing mandate but is the
fight over for good plus from hero to
star witness we look ahead to the waffle
house shooting trial who the prosecution
may call and from defendant to attorney
michael avenatti will represent himself
in federal court but first closing
arguments in wisconsin versus theodore
edge code the victim said words he
punched him when the victim gets ready
for a fight he kills him law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin prosecutors and defense attorneys
make their final plea to the jury
wednesday with closing arguments in the
case of wisconsin first theodore edgeco
it was the last chance for edgecombe's
legal team to present its argument of
self-defense
in september 2020 edgecombe was riding
his bike when he says immigration
attorney jason clearman and his wife
swiped him with their car causing him to
fall over video footage shows edgecombe
punched clearman through his open
passenger side window after that the car
follows edgecomb on tuesday the
defendant testified that he quote feared
for his life when the couple followed
him security footage shows clearman get
out of the car and confront edgco that's
when he shot clearman after that
prosecutors say edgecombe fled the state
he was arrested six months later in
kentucky ahead of closing arguments
wednesday jury instructions were
discussed judge david barowski ruled
jurors will determine whether edgcomb
intentionally shot clearman or whether
it was in self-defense jurors have
several options to discuss in
deliberations edgecombe's charge of
first-degree intentional homicide or
lesser charges like secondary
intentional homicide first or
second-degree reckless homicide or
negligent homicide while the defendant
has always maintained self-defense he
testified quote the gun just went off
when he lunged forward that's when i
stepped back
and there was a reaction as far as like
the gun just went off as far as
when i stepped back
down forward
if the gun goes off pointed down
how does mr clearman get one in his
eyebrow
with only a slightly upward trajectory
his head he was like lunging towards me
like he was going to spear me or tackle
me and now i step back when you step
back did you pull the gun up
when you step back did you pull the gun
up
at that moment it
it did go up because i stepped back it
was reaction there
just a reaction so you're saying you
didn't mean to shoot him
there was no intent there no i was
total accident he got shot
yes there was no intent there thank you
very much
in wednesday's closing arguments
prosecutor told jurors edgecombe did not
act in self-defense and highlighted
evidence they say proves it
four people
saw that gun in his hand
not because it's down by the side and
all there's a lot item or it they saw
the gun
and what's the defendant do after that
ladies and gentlemen
he runs
and all we know is he never comes back
the gun that he used
according to him
he just throws it out the window because
he you know doesn't want someone to
shoot him with it something that meant
that he kept on to it held on to this
murder weapon for weeks through two
states until all of a sudden he hits the
cornfields of indiana as though some
voice comes out and says if you ditch it
they won't find you and then ladies and
gentlemen it's all oh the victim must
have had a knife and when that falls
apart because their witness doesn't see
anything in the wife's hands and there's
no evidence to support he had anything
not one single witness supports that all
of a sudden at the 11th hour we go from
yep i was defending myself to it's an
accident
during the defense's closing court was
interrupted when a juror got sick
closing continued with edgecombe's legal
team countering the prosecution saying
the defendant was trying to stop
clearman from hurting him
now the state will say oh
we can't we can't trust this testimony
well let's let's talk about his
testimony
you heard him come understand and say
that if i could do this over
yeah i was upset yes i was infuriated
but if i had another chance to do this
i would simply accept being hit by a
vehicle thrown into another
and being caught and
if you recall on cross-examination he
talked about
you know
the gun went off after he lunged at me
you recall that
he said it a couple of times
mr axcom believes that
he's already made it clear
that he shot mr clearman
he intended
to shoot mr clearman to stop a threat
he did not however intend to kill
someone
joining us today is legal analyst kirk
nermey and terry austin kirk edgecombe
testified the shooting was unintentional
now there are arguments that
self-defense shouldn't apply does it
well he certainly didn't do himself any
favors in saying things that way because
self-defense is an act of justification
you're justified in taking that life
because yours are threatened it has
nothing to do with accident so probably
from a strict legal perspective you can
make the argument that no then the
self-defense doesn't apply given that
testimony and after when we heard jury
instructions we heard that
good back and forth between the
attorneys making that point and
fortunately for mr edgecombe the judge
was willing to let that in because there
was some evidence to that effect but yes
he was in the potential of losing that
very valuable defense the defense his
attorneys have been asserting the whole
time because of his choice to try to
alter his testimony maybe to what he
heard or what his jailhouse lawyers told
him yeah now terry it makes sense
edgecombe's attorney probably said to
him if you don't understand a question
ask to clarify but was it too much and
did it sound credible to you
well i do think that his attorney
probably instructed him and said listen
if you don't understand tell them to
repeat it or rephrase it but he did it a
little bit too much he just kept saying
it and it was very annoying and i'm sure
the jury was not happy about that and so
what i will say is i do think mr lamar
did a good job explaining at the end of
the day why it was that edgecombe was
saying these things repeatedly one he
has add two he was very afraid because
it's a serious case and three he was
basically saying he was afraid of the
prosecution
all right we'll see how this continues
the case is now in the juror's hands as
to whether or not theodore edgecombe is
guilty in the killing of jason clearman
or with self-defense
on to news out of kentucky where former
louisville police officer brett
hankinson appeared in court ahead of his
trial hankinson is charged with three
counts of wanton endangerment in
connection to the shooting at brianna
taylor's apartment prosecutors say
hankinson endangered the safety of
people in an apartment neighboring
tailors at a hearing on wednesday both
sides argued over media coverage of
upcoming jury selection
the public can't be prevented from
physically seeing the jurors they will
be sitting in the jury box during the
trial in open court and any suggestion
that
you know the public seeing the jurors is
somehow going to destroy a fair trial
simply can't stand up to that fact that
the trial itself has to be conducted
openly i'm not asking that the media be
barred from the hallway outside the
courtroom or from the front steps of the
courthouse
i just think that the media should not
be in the courtroom
influencing these jurors in a number of
ways
in my opinion mainly mainly negative
ways
such that
we can't have can't get an impartial
jury for mr hankinson i think it's one
thing for people to come down to the
courthouse and sit in on a trial it's a
very different thing to be
putting the jurors
images on on the television
so
i would be instructing
the media to not do that
in the end judge smith ruled individual
voldeer will not be completely closed to
the news media or public a lengthy jury
selection process is expected to begin
on friday
still ahead on law and crime daily years
after the deadly waffle house shooting
jury selection begins for suspect travis
rankin but first does grace attorney
michael avenatti representing himself in
the stormy daniels federal trial will
you now question the prosecution's star
witness
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
co-host terry austin joins us now for
the latest on a deadly shooting out of
new york
brian a second new york police officer
has died from his injuries following a
shooting last week in harlem officer
wilbert moore died tuesday he and his
partner rookie jason rivera were shot
while responding to a domestic incident
the mother of the suspected shooter
lashawn mcneal called police saying she
needed help with her son
police said a third officer shot and
killed mcneal when he fired at maura and
rivera detectives said they found an
ar-15 under mcneal's mattress while
searching the home a different gun from
the murder weapon mayor eric adams
called for an end to the violence and
said five officers have been shot
recently
it is our city against the killers
this was just not an attack
on three brave officers
this was an attack
on the city of new york
and it's an attack
on the children and families of this
city
officer moore's organs were harvested
for donation to help others brian back
to you
thanks terry in federal court a shocking
move as michael avenatti chooses to
represent himself on charges he stole
money from former client story daniels
on tuesday a judge ruled avenatti could
represent himself meaning he will likely
cross-examine the prosecution's star
witness stormy daniels daniels will
likely take the stand later this week
avenatti rose to fame while representing
the adult film actress whose real name
is stephanie clifford she accused former
president donald trump of providing her
with hush money payments to quiet news
of their affair avenatti now faces
charges for stealing 300 000
out of an advance for daniel's memoir
about her affair with trump prosecutors
say avenatti forged her signature and
later lied to her about where the money
was going an
indictment says he used the money to pay
law firm employees and for personal
expenses like making a luxury car
payment if convicted avenatti faces 22
years in prison
let's bring back legal analyst kirk
nermey and terry austin to discuss this
major shift in representation terry the
saying goes an attorney that represents
himself has a fool of a client
do you think that applies here
i'm sorry yes no question about it brian
i'm so excited about it yes he's a fool
for doing that the old adage absolutely
applies first of all you need the
resources of an attorney to help you
prepare for the case they're going to do
the research they're going to do the
openings and the closings you know
second of all it's the jury's perception
that you think you know everything and
you know so much that you can do it
better than your lawyer could do it and
thirdly in my humble opinion i think
that you're too personally invested when
you're trying to represent yourself it's
going to be interesting to see him do it
but i think it's going to hurt the case
at the end of the day
all right kirk so i'm not going to be
representing myself for any future cases
is what i've learned but all eyes are
going to be on avenatti likely
cross-examining stormy daniels how's
that going to work and is there an
advantage to being defendant and lawyer
yeah certainly don't we all wish we had
the cameras in the courtroom to see that
cross-examination and i think for the
most part terry's right but you know
regarding having a fool for a client but
you know there's reports about his
attorney his public defender doing 45
minutes of cross-examination on a
witness and none of it the judge said
was relevant made the attorney sit down
so kind of in that instance maybe this
is a situation where it is wise for mr
avenatti to go forward and while he's
personally invested that could be an
advantage also in terms of his knowledge
he's going to cross-examine his own
client which again should be should make
for great viewing but also he's going to
know things and be able to react to what
she says quicker than a public defender
who didn't have first-hand knowledge of
it would so i think the
cross-examination could could be that
much more rigorous agree i know part of
this is that this is just simply a
contract agreement that stormy daniels
is kind of going back on at least that's
the argument we'll see how it plays out
coming up on law and crime daily the
vitamin administration drops its covet
vaccination mandate what that means for
you
plus jury selection is underway in the
so-called waffle house shooting we look
ahead to trial and who the prosecution
may call as a star witness
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily day
two of jury selection in the high
profile case in tennessee that of travis
ranking the accused gunman in a mass
shooting out of antioch waffle house
nearly four years ago
ranking was has pled not guilty to 17
counts including first degree murder for
the shooting deaths of the ebony groves
joe perez aquila da silva and tyron
toronton it happened in the early
morning of april 22nd 2018. prosecutors
say ranking mcphaly shot two people in
the restaurant's parking lot before
opening fire inside killing two more
people and injuring several others after
a 34-hour manhunt ranking was arrested
he faces life in prison one man who was
at the restaurant that morning james
charles jr stopped the gunman and in
turn may have saved more people from
being shot
he has been hailed a hero and could
likely testify in the trial ranking was
previously deemed incompetent to stand
trial and was treated for schizophrenia
jury selection which started tuesday has
been a difficult task given the media
coverage of the case opening statements
are set to begin on monday
legal analyst kirk nermey and co-host
terry austin join us again to break down
the waffle house shooting
terry i respect james shaw jr's opinion
i totally get it but to me he's a hero
so
how do you think having a hero testify
against a defendant will play out for
ranking
ryan there's no question that the jury
is going to be very sympathetic i mean
this man risked his life and he could
have easily been killed and i think it's
the testimony that the jury is going to
really admire they're going to respect
it they're going to have sympathy and
when you compare that to the actual
defendant who kills someone i think the
jury is definitely going to lean in
favor obviously of making this
individual guilty absolutely now kirk
bizarre facts are likely to come out of
this case as you saw um shaw jr had his
hand wrapped there because the barrel of
the gun was so hot it burned his hand
and ranking was naked but for the jacket
he had on top of him how will these
facts play into the case
well i think ultimately you know because
mr ranking might be using some mental
health defense he's been treated for
schizophrenia some of those bizarre
facts could at least give the jury
insight into that the validity of that
but i think ultimately you know this is
what we would call in the criminal
defense business a long-form guilty plea
because we have so many witnesses
against him we have mr shaw jr who
stopped a potentially even more horrific
scene and i think the horrific nature of
this crime the extent of it the extent
of what could happen is what the jury is
going to be fixated on and ultimately no
matter how long this long form guilty
plea takes i think at the end mr ranking
is going to find himself convicted on
all 17 counts bizarre facts aside all
right we'll see how it plays out make
sure to check out the law and crime
network for gavin will capital coverage
when we come back the biden
administration drops his covet
vaccination regulation after the supreme
court blocked the mandate what the
occupational safety and health
administration says is next that's ahead
on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily in
coba news the biden administration drops
its vaccination mandate after a
monumental supreme court defeat
effective wednesday the occupational
safety and health administration better
known as osha says it's pulling vaccine
and testing requirements earlier this
month scotus blocked the mandate after
the binding administration called for
all employees to be vaccinated or submit
to weekly coven 19 tests for companies
with more than 100 employees scotus
ruled osha overstepped his authority by
issuing the mandate under its emergency
powers
the labor department says osha will now
ask courts to dismiss lawsuits relating
to the mandate those lawsuits stem from
republican-led states private businesses
national trade associations and
religious groups in response to the
vaccine requirement a statement from the
labor department says in part quote osha
is evaluating and the record and the
evolving course of the pandemic osha has
made no determinations at this time
about when or if it will finalize a
vaccination and testing rule from here
the bind administration has asked
businesses to voluntarily implement the
vaccine requirements
meanwhile justice stephen breyer
announces he will retire from the
supreme court at the end of the current
term 83-year-old justice breyer is the
oldest supreme court justice he has
served on the court for more than 27
years notably he is one of the three
remaining liberal justices briar's
decision to step down now means
president joe biden can appoint a
successor that could serve for decades
right now the court is split six to
three between conservative and liberal
justices
kirk osho's withdrawing its vaccine
mandate what happens to the pending
lawsuits and what does that mean for
businesses
well ultimately as far as it relates to
the pending lawsuits most of those are
going to be rendered mood the decision
the supreme court is the law the land
the ruling should take care of all the
most the bulk of those lawsuits and
render them moot so then it becomes then
with no law guidance no no
imposition of mandates on the businesses
businesses are going to have to decide
for themselves both in terms of their
relationship to the public how they want
to present themselves on what has become
an exceedingly political issue and how
they want to protect their workers do
they want to impose that that on their
workers so that they can keep maintain
their staff we see a lot of businesses
with shortages et cetera so now it's
going to be up to each and every
business to decide how they want to
proceed and we'll see where that plays
out state by state and city by city
terry talk to us about justice breyer's
legacy and how his retiring maintain
scotus for decades to come
oh it will definitely change the whole
supreme court listen he was and is a
brilliant justice he was appointed by
clinton in 1994 and like he said he
served on the bench for almost 28 years
and the only other justice who has
served as long is clarence thomas he
served three years longer
you can just say that breyer is
considered liberal although he doesn't
like to be
announced as being liberal he thinks it
should be apolitical but he definitely
is along with justice kagan and justice
sotomayor he wrote a book actually on
making our democracy work that is his
legacy he says basically whether you
have laws or rules doesn't matter if the
people have to do it all right we'll see
how the supreme court changes over the
course of the next coming weeks thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you